a du mal à se remettre de ses émotions
deux jours après son arrestation à
l'hôpital à Santo Domingo
c'est une des nouvelles tactiques de la
police dominicaine repérer les femmes
haïtiennes enceintes sans papier qui
viennent accoucher dans les hôpitaux de
la capitale
Nike à Pierre a été accueilli par une
ONG haïtienne à belader petite ville
frontalière qui constitue un des points
de passage important entre les deux pays
on a des migrants qui témoignent à avoir
été victime de maltraitance et des
brutalités les policiers et certaines
migrants témoignages avoir été gazé à
l'intérieur des prisons c'est où
fonctionnaire dominicains responsable
des relations de son pays avec Haïti se
dit lui aussi outré par la manière
utilisée lors de ses expulsions massives
ordonnées par le président Luis aminader
mais où Ortega partage les inquiétudes
de son gouvernement 30%
en santé
de ministère de la Santé de service
national de santé c'est de penser en
attendant
[Musique]
ce père de famille habitait à Marty
centre quartier de Port-au-Prince ravagé
par la guerre des gangs armées depuis
juin 2021 il attendait visa pour
immigrer qui n'arrivait pas incapable de
travailler et c'est enfui avec sa femme
et son fils est-ce que vous aviez peur
pour vous et votre famille à cause de la
violence
il a été arrêté et refoulé sans avoir le
temps d'aviser sa femme bien des fois si
dort maintenant ici elle est
complètement démunie elle vivait depuis
6 ans en République Dominicaine avec sa
mère et le père de ses enfants tous sans
papiers comme la grande majorité des
Haïtiens exilés dans ce pays
Naika enceinte de ces mois et sa
fillette de 15 mois ont été transportés
dans un camion comme celui-ci
où les gens sont entassés debout sans
eau ni nourriture pendant des heures
le poste frontière de beladair et
fréquenté par des commerçants en tout
genre
et par des Haïtiens qui cherchent à fuir
la crise mais ces jours-ci la plupart
sont forcés de faire le trajet inverse
on la pratique les personnes à 8h15 dans
la soirée et hier soir on était à la
frontière pour recevoir plus de 200
personnes selon des médias dominicains
entre 800 et 1000 haïtiens illégaux sont
expulsés chaque jour depuis le décret
présidentiel du 11 novembre
plus que nous ce qui se passe ici je
vous dis c'est inhumain et c'est
impossible de continuer avec ça mais on
veut pas recevoir des des leçons des
comportements surtout des États-Unis
ces adolescents ont aussi été expulsés
par les autorités dominicaines certains
d'entre eux ont été séparés de leurs
parents ils sont accueillis par une ONG
spécialisée partenaires de l'UNICEF
passer plus de deux semaines en prison
pas accès à l'eau à la nourriture tout
ça la couleur
la Commission des droits de l'homme des
Nations Unies exige que ces déportations
massives cessent le temps qu'on trouve
une solution à la crise haïtienne la
communauté internationale doit prendre
cette situation charge et fait un plan
Marshall qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
je vais retourner
Naika la jeune maman se demande de quel
côté de la frontière elle pourra
accoucher dans les prochaines semaines
peut-être avec sa grand-mère en Haïti ou
avec son mari à
souhaite retourner
[Musique]